Cybersecurity is a unique challenge
today because when we are so utterly
dependent upon our digital
communications and our digital control
of things,
and so it's going to become evermore
essential that we have the ability to
provide security that we're confident
in.
The challenge is if we were against
doctor know or Mr big in a cave
somewhere,
you could understand the threat and you
could sort of limit the threat and the
threat would have a.
A predictable limitation and what they
could do.
They'd have to pick an avenue of
approach and they'd have to go at that
avenue of approach because they can't do
all things at all times.
The problem with Cybersecurity,
that's not the threat.
There are some entities like that.
There's some state sponsored entities
that are focused on certain things,
but the barrier to entry into the cyber
world is very low.
You can get in your basement,
in your boxer shorts and you can have a
computer and you can get into the game
and it's sort of the idea of 10,000
monkeys typing on 10,000 keyboards.
Somebody's going to create a
cybersecurity challenge and so and it's
constantly morphing and adapting,
whereas the cybersecurity requirement is
to protect things so you essentially
have to protect everything that you
value all the time.
The people who want to attack that can
attack at their choosing wherever they
want and constantly changed their
attacks constantly.
Just like water goes against a damn.
It just goes until it finds the weakest
point.
At some point something happens,
technology changes,
human error,
technological glitch or whatever.
There's a good likelihood that they'll
get in.
And so if you think about the
cybersecurity problem,
the first thing I don't think will work
is the Maginot line.
You know,
the Maginot line was created by the
French in the 19 thirties to prevent the
Germans from doing a repeat of the first
world war and invading France from
Germany.
People think of it now is the stupidest
thing ever built,
but it's not really correct because the
Maginot line actually worked.
The Germans did not invade across the
German French border.
Now,
the fact is they went through Belgium.
They still got into France and conquered
France and the summer 1940,
so I think the lesson to be learned is
there have to be defensive things set up
as best we can for cybersecurity,
but it's going to have to be this
constantly adapting,
constantly morphing defense-in-depth
with some offense to with going out and
figuring out where the threats are
arising and that that defense in depth
means that you can't have one line.
The government can't put a big wall up
and everybody hides behind it.
Nor do we want each organization,
each commercial firm or government
organization to be an island under
themselves,
just hoping that they are not the
weakest willdabeast in the herd and that
the lines of get somebody else.
What we really need is all of those
entities to be linked so they constantly
learn from one another.
If one suffers a breach,
everyone has to learn from it.
Right now,
the challenge is people are low.
The share that information,
one,
because commercially they might be hurt
by reputation.
Also,
they're afraid that the more you share,
the more you have the event,
the,
uh,
possibility of your little island is not
completely separated your moat around it
has got linkages across it and you can
be opened up more,
but we're going to have to get a network
to defense where every time something
happens and we learned from it,
the entire network learns immediately.
We're going to have to have that kind of
speed because there will be breaches,
there will be mistakes,
but the organism,
organisms,
gotta learn.
It's going to have to be a lot like the
human immune system.
The human immune system is extraordinary
because about 10,000 times a day it gets
attacked by something that could hurt
the human body,
but as it responds and it sends out an
antibodies to it,
it does it and it learns from that.
And so that has a breach one time.
It actually builds up antibodies against
that challenge and has them at the ready
for the next time.
That's how we build up immunity to
things,
and I think the human immune system is
the way our cyber defense is going to
have to be,
which means that it has to be
integrated.